well hundreds of immigrants and
advocates are in town for the country's
biggest conference after the pandemic
forced last year's event to go virtual
for one immigrant this conference brings
hope for a better life
the american dream for me is being
independent enough and stable enough
where i'm able to spend time with my
kids lisa salinas dream is a reflection
of what many immigrants strive for every
day in the u.s a key focus during the
biggest immigration summit getting
everybody hurt and we want everybody to
have a voice and know that they have
rights the four-day national immigration
integration conference has over 3 500
major advocates in person and online
gathered at the west gate discussing
health care economy solidarity and
migration our field is just ever
expanding and so diverse and we have
crisis after crisis that keep up ending
our potential progress even president
joe biden sending this virtual message
of encouragement i strongly support
giving dreamers tps recipients and farm
workers the long-awaited pathway to
permanent residents and eventual
citizenship i think they all deserve
advocates say the pandemic had a major
impact on immigrants and nine months of
the biden administration brings new hope
for this population we were there for
the united states and now what we're
asking is that the united states and
fellow americans be there for us very
concretely that we finally have a path
to legalization a path this young woman
hopes will turn her dream into a reality
we all want a better life for ourselves
for our family and for our future kids